what's up
hey everybody it is July 19
2022. I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's David's birthday around here
so we started the day with donuts so if
I'm a little sluggish if I seem a little
carb loaded a little sugar heavy you
know why I'm gonna plow through if the
clips are a little slow Connor had a lot
of donuts today his his finger might not
be working the The Prompt there may be a
little slower we're going to do
everything we can I'm just saying
there's a lot of sugar in the system
right now we are going to try to play
through it is David's birthday uh I
don't want to give everything away in
case he's watching the show right now
but later today the entire team we're
getting a whole bunch of guns and we're
going to a field out there in Florida
we're going to shoot some stuff because
that's what you do on your birthday when
you live in Florida what are we going to
shoot do we know what we're shooting I
assume iguanas and rats big rats swamp
creatures other such things
yes okay good we're gonna shoot some
stuff uh anyway uh we got a big show for
you today uh we are going to juxtapose
the uh Elites versus the regular people
and how all of the wokeness the
craziness the globalist nonsense the
climate change BS all of this stuff that
they're pushing on us is not anything
that is important or relevant to any of
our daily lives it's just a way of
controlling us but many of you well
especially you guys watching this but
many regular people as well because
you're special people if you're watching
this and I mean especially not you're
not a special person you're a special
people uh you uh you get it and you're
not being duped by this stuff anymore
and I think more and more people are
actually not being duped by it the the
endless fear of covid coming back and
you're gonna die because of climate
change and all the stuff I just think
people aren't buying it anymore but we
just gotta keep pushing and we need just
to keep fostering that overwhelming
sense that so many any of us have right
now which is just let's just reject this
left this won't Progressive nonsense
let's expose them for the devil
worshiping weirdos that they are and
let's figure out better ways to live
that is the plan and uh that's what
we're going to keep doing over here and
then we're going to shoot iguanas this
afternoon before we get to any of that
let me talk to you about modern private
wine you know you've heard me talk about
the amazing extreme altitude wines from
Bonner private wine before well I just
had a bottle last night of their nine
thousand foot Malbec uh while I was
eating a nice rib eye it's grilling
season and the flavors go great with any
meat you're going to have they're unlike
any wine you've ever tasted Blackberry
leather smoke a little dark cherry these
wines are almost impossible to get on
your own the producers deep in the Andes
Mountains make a very limited quantity
today I have an amazing offer that I've
never had before if you visit
bonnerprivatewines.com Dave you'll not
only get wine for over 50 off plus free
shipping but you'll also get a bonus
bottle of small batch limited production
wine from their exclusive Wine Cellar
that's four bottles for the price of
three it's a deal that's hard to turn
down if you're a wine lover like me just
visit bonnerprivatewines.com Dave to
claim your bonus bottle and become part
of America's most unique wine club
that's bonnerprivatewise.com Dave to get
your wine today okay now let's talk
about the elites because there is a
group of people whether they're the
world economic Forum or their Stooges
like Justin Trudeau up in Canada or
people that are Loosely connected but
are just you know power hungry lunatics
like Gavin Newsom in California who
preach one thing to all of us but do not
behave that way in their own private
lives and it's becoming increasingly
obvious that the only reason that
they're constantly telling us that we're
about to die that the Earth is going to
swallow us whole that disease is
everywhere and that if we just gave them
more of our money and more of our rights
then we'd be safe uh it's all a gimmick
it is all a shell game to keep us
controlled and needy and not take
responsibility for our own lives I don't
buy it I don't think you buy it but this
guy Prince Harry who well I guess he's
ex he's ex-prince he's X Prince he's not
a prince anymore he gave up the prince
ship because he married this Meghan
Markle and she's a woke Wackadoo so she
basically said you can't be a prince
anymore and your whole family's racist
we'll get to that in a second well
anyway Prince Harry Rex Prince Harry he
gave a talk at the U.N and the U.N is a
very corrupt organization uh it used to
be something about getting a whole bunch
of countries together to see if we could
do any good in the world now it's just
like the worst countries running the
craziest you know anti-western programs
that you can imagine anyway Prince Harry
gave a big talk at the the U.N and he's
very concerned about a whole bunch of
stuff that is completely ridiculous this
has been a painful year in a painful
decade
we're living through a pandemic that
continues to ravage communities in every
corner of the globe
climate change wreaking havoc on our
planet
with the most vulnerable suffering most
of all
the few weaponizing lies and
disinformation at the expense of the
many
and from the horrific war in Ukraine to
the rolling back of constitutional
rights here in the United States we are
witnessing a global Assault on democracy
and freedom the cause of Mandela's life
it's so extraordinary how these people
operate i i in some ways it's not that
I'm jealous of it because I I don't want
to lie it's not something I'm interested
in but I'm like curious about it like
how can you lie about everything I
cannot fathom
I mentioned this often and many of you
bring this up to me and it often comes
up in my q and A's like how can these
people just lie about everything could
they be so like confused by their own
nonsense could they so live in another
world as us like it's just so crazy he
says a few things there first it's a
very painful year and a painful decade I
mean I would recommend that any of you
uh read actual data on any of these
things humans are living longer than
ever before we have less poverty than
ever before actually Wars and things are
way down there was more clean water
there is more uh there's more potable
water there's more you know more
aggregation and more land that people
can grow food on the the world is
greener then it's been like it's just
sort of crazy but they need you to be in
a constant state of fear so the year has
been horrible and the decade has been a
nightmare that either the pandemic is
still raging communities everywhere you
know it's crazy because I Googled raging
communities pandemic couldn't find one
Hospital Hospital in the entire world on
planet Earth One hospital right now that
is overrun by Kobe I couldn't find one
place say in Africa where they don't
have great water where they don't have
great sanitation they don't have uh you
know fully equipped hospitals with The
Cutting Edge Equipment and I couldn't
find one Hospital there's just dead
people everywhere couldn't find it
couldn't find it the entire way through
the pandemic couldn't even find it in
San Francisco and that place is a
[ __ ] could not find it then of
course we have to worry about climate
change that I think that's ravaging
communities too got to watch out for the
climate change
just nonsense just nonsense his buddy
Barack Obama you know he just bought a
house in Martha's Vineyard massive 25 30
million dollar house right on the water
so climate change is coming the water is
rising I'm going to buy a house uh right
on the ledge over there because that's
how much I believe it and I'm going to
be buddies with John Kerry who flies a
private plane all over the country and
God only knows what he's injecting his
face with but that stuff can't be good
for the environment either uh and then
the people that are weaponizing
misinformation well here's a guy who
just spread all of this misinformation
about how crazy the covet is and climate
change and all that but other people are
weaponizing this information I mean you
get it but this is what these people do
they just get up there and they wear
their fancy suits and they eat their
foie gras and they tell you that
horrible things are happening and
somehow their lives are all okay but
your life is going to be very very
affected by all of the craziness but
everything going on right now
all of the craziness has been ushered in
by these woke leftist lunatics and these
people who are just trying to grasp
power wherever they can see it they feel
like they're losing the game in a way
right like that seems to be what's
happening here that the internet for all
it's it's dark parts of the internet
which there are plenty and all of the
divisiveness and all of those things
it's enabled a bunch of us to to see
that the emperor has no clothes that
these people who are supposedly in
charge are not smarter than us they're
not better than us they're not they're
not worthy of of our attention or our
our respect in many ways
um and they are usually the ones who are
ushering in all the division they are
clamoring against so here now is a video
you may remember this this was uh this
is about a year ago I think originally
right uh I think he was Prince at the
time it was before he was X Prince we
had the artist formerly named Prince
right he was the artist formerly named
Prince now we got the X Prince this is
Harry and Meghan Markle and uh she has
just I don't even care care that much
about the monarchy in England I think
there's something interesting about a
monarchy and something that's supposed
to stand the test of time and last
political administrations and all of
those things but I don't generally talk
about the monarchy that much I did like
the crown on Netflix pretty decent uh
but Harry and Megan sat down with Oprah
and uh she told Harry and everybody else
that they're a bunch of freaking racists
so we have in tandem the conversation of
he won't be given security he's not
going to be given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what later Harry joins the interview but
he refuses to elaborate on who said it
that conversation I'm never going to
share
okay so you have to understand these
people like this guy think of like the
level of power this kid was born into by
pure happenstance right his bloodline
somehow
and and whatever is in The Ether of life
he was put on this Earth and he is the
prince to the crown right and he could
have done so much good so he marries
this woman and now he's apologizing for
all sorts of things he won't be referred
to as Prince anymore the monarchy is
racist and all of these things and then
he brings this guilt and I guess that's
what so much of this is about these
people who have succeeded on the backs
of others feel guilt about it they feel
an unending guilt there is a a cavern
there is an endless Bottomless Pit in
their stomach of guilt that they cannot
fill up properly so he brings this woman
in she's now destroying his entire
family's Legacy and in many ways I think
undermining the very basic beliefs of
what the United Kingdom is all about why
the monarchy has lasted this long
whether you love the monarchy or not
whether you think it's silly and the
outfits are ridiculous and all of those
things like the idea of this thing that
lasts political uh administrations over
time like that there are things and
standards that exist I think there is
some value to that okay we can talk
about the the stuff that may be over the
top on the margin but she comes in
you're a whole bunch of racists and he's
given up his title and everything else
and I think and then you see then the
reason I'm showing you this then you see
this guy with all of this guilt going to
the United Nations telling you that
you're gonna die because of the disease
that's everywhere the virus and you're
also going to have problems because of
climate change and the other people with
misinformation and racism is running
rampant and all of these things these
things are connected somehow that's what
I'm trying to show you uh here's a video
from a little bit after that this is
British TV Piers Morgan and Piers Morgan
is a complete blowhard who just wants
ratings I get it but half the time he
makes some sense that half the time he's
a complete lunatic but here he was sort
of right then he loses it sort of right
about that people have just had it with
like all of this BS racist nonsense and
the people who give into it let me talk
about the program it doesn't really
matter what I think of Meghan Markle
doesn't matter whether I believe her or
not what matters is the damage that she
is accused of doing to the royal family
and let me ask you honestly on the issue
of race she has now got the whole of
America and the worst of the world
frankly looking upon the palace the
monarchy the queen everyone in the royal
family as a bunch of racists I don't
think she has but yet you continue to
trash her okay I'm done with this no no
sorry no sorry do you know what that's
pretty attractive maybe not no no no no
I'm being sorry
absolutely diabolical Behavior you see
I'm sorry but Pierce spouts off on a
regular basis and we all have to sit
there and listen 6 30 to 7 o'clock
yesterday was incredibly hard to watch
okay so the reason I'm showing you that
is that Piers is sort of right that you
bring in this woman now now the the
monarchy is like falling apart like we
shouldn't just
um we shouldn't just be excited about
the destruction of Institutions right
Jordan Peterson talks about this and
actually in in his last book in the
second book 12 more rules uh he talks
about this quite extensively it's like
we're watching institutions crumble and
maybe certain institutions do but you
have to really think what are you going
to replace them with and as we watch our
institutions crumble all across America
it's not like we're building that many
great things sort of at a national level
we're building them certainly at a state
level there are some good things
happening I happen to live in a state
that's leading on that front
um but anyway peers makes an interesting
point then we just threw in the other
part because he's also just like a
television blowhard who just gets up
like imagine being so offended by what
that guy said that's it I'm taking my
microphone off I'm storming like imagine
if one of you guys offended me why would
Michael you're yawning right now I just
turned to you you're literally yawning
as I what if I was just I'm not kidding
he's yawning right the donut right it is
the donut the sugar it gets you but
imagine if I was just like Michael's
yawning while I'm talking and I just rip
this thing off and then walked out how
long would you keep the stream going
what would you do
Phoenix would jump in you jump in
anyway little sidebar just like the
theatrics of Television but all of this
shows I think a broader theme of these
left-wing woke celebrities and
politicians who are grifting it's not
even necessarily that they're gifting
for money they're gifting for attention
and power and normal people have just
had it so as long as we're talking about
the UK and the British people who are an
older people than us and wise people
people with a certain degree of decorum
and things of that nature let's talk
about JK Rowling
who of course was the author of Harry
Potter who was a beloved uh character
and a beloved book Michael you love
those uh that Harry Potter there and uh
you know thank you for not yawning when
I said that
um Harry Potter was loved JK Rowling was
loved but of course now because she
defends women against uh having their
genitals chopped off she's a bad chick
here's some info from the daily wire
author J.K Rowling threw her support
behind Macy Gray after the singer faced
backlash for what some called
transphobic comments when she said
changing your part doesn't make you a
woman gray was labeled a Turf a
derogatory acronym used by some leftists
that stands for transgender exclusionary
radical feminists after saying on Piers
Morgans Piers Morgan's uncensored show
that just because you go change your
parts doesn't make you a woman sorry
today feels like a good day to ensure
I've bought Macy Gray's entire back
catalog Rowling tweeted her 13 million
followers Tuesday rolling the famed
Harry Potter author has also been the
target of trans rights activists because
of her defense of biological women's
rights and protections so to be clear
about JK Rowling what got her in this
mess I mean again this was this was a
beloved woman who wrote you know the the
Star Wars of
our time right you first had you had
Lord of the Rings then you had Star Wars
then you had Harry Potter like this is
the thing that so many kids who are
becoming adults right now this is the
stuff that their dreams were made of
right and it was great it was actually
even though Harry Potter I'm like I'm a
little old for it but like the stories
and the meaning of the stories and the
consistency and and the actually what
the stories were telling you were pretty
deep powerful things uh she was loved by
everybody then she dares say hey uh you
know uh girls or girls and boys or boys
now she's a bad guy and then of course
Macy Gray who said you know just because
you change your genitals you're not
really changing your sex uh now she's a
bad chick although she apologized we
showed you that video last week the like
most pathetic apology I've ever seen but
it shows the insanity of the left
they're going after anyone who basically
States things that we all know to be
true uh here's a tweet from The Blaze
what's going on over at you pen
UPenn nominates transgender swimmer Leah
Thomas as 2022 woman of the year
now as I say on this topic I don't mean
to be a dick about it but she is a dude
uh Leah Thomas has a penis
we did some research on that
now I'm going to rip the mic off and
walk out of Leah Thomas has a penis
that's it I'm out of here
um it's complete nonsense you could I
suppose and remember she she ranks
something like 467th when she was a male
now she's a female with a penis and she
ranks the number one number she's the
number one
it doesn't make any sense and also
wouldn't the penis bog you down at that
point like if you're going to swim as a
chick wouldn't you get rid of the penis
just for the ability to get through
water faster
yeah
oh it's a propeller that's funny that's
funny man Donuts work with you uh anyway
it's all nonsense we all we know it's
all nonsense but it continues at the
highest levels of government here is
assistant secretary for health Rachel
Levine and she wants to do weird shift
kids so we really want to to to to
debase our treatment and uh and to
affirm and to uh support and Empower
these youth not to limit their
participation and activities to sports
and even a limit their ability to get
gender affirmation treatment in their
state
all right so that gal was dude for about
45 years of her life I think married to
a woman has kids blah blah blah decides
to transition or whatever's going on
there that's fine with me as an adult
like you can do whatever you want what's
dangerous about that is what he she
whatever said at the end which is that
they she basically he she wants to put
these kids on puberty blockers you know
in other countries if this was happening
in the Middle East and they were like oh
we're going to chop off kids genitals
and we're gonna all of this stuff people
would not be that thrilled about it
right people would not be that thrilled
and then it would be the left calling
those people uh islamophobes or
something
um
but it's just nonsense like that is
Health disinformation right they talk
about misinformation all the time if you
are interested in just affirming what a
seven-year-old says I'm a girl today and
you're like oh you are a girl and I'm
gonna drug you
you are insane you are legitimately
crazy and you should be studied at an
Institute in Sweden probably that's what
we should be doing with you people uh
but it does not just end there as they
are trying to turn your sons into
daughters and daughters into Sons
they're trying to freak you out about
covet again it's back baby uh so we've
got more on that here we go uh here is
Biden's covid coordinator Dr Ashish
and she psyched because L.A county is
bringing back the masks L.A County
announced this week that if cases
continue on the same trajectory they
will have an indoor mask mandate it
looks likely that that will happen I
assume that's something you support
should should other states look at this
yeah my view on this has been for really
for two years well before I came into
this kind of role my view on this has
been very clear which is uh local
jurisdiction cities uh counties States
should make decisions about Mass
mandates because communities are
different uh and their patterns of
transmission are different that said CDC
has very clear guidance on this as well
through the through their covet
Community levels and and the CDC
recommendation is that when you're in a
high Zone that sort of orange Zone as
L.A county is uh you know people wearing
masks indoors is really important and it
really will make a difference all right
first off I have to apologize I I called
a shisha she as I entered the clip it's
just I'm so confused about all this
stuff and I'm trying to be respectful to
everybody and maybe he wears dresses at
night I don't know so I was just trying
to be nice but from what I could tell
there rashish jaw is a dude but suddenly
and by the way Martha raddatz great
great guy great guy really great guy
um but
suddenly the same people
who wanted complete Federal control over
everything Remember When Donald Trump
was President even though they were
calling him Hitler they were demanding
he do more and what did everyone hate
Donald Trump for he said hey States
figure it out and they said you are
Hitler and Hitler we just wish you had
more power to do more things because
everything that they say and do is
ridiculous but the meme has gone out
it's this is what I mean about you got
to give the devil is due and watch how
the machine morphs right in front of our
eyes it's incredible it's absolutely
incredible you've got devil worshipers
like Gavin Newsom now talking about
localism he's into localism and Ashish
John what for the last two years I've
been talking about how local
jurisdictions ought to do things a
little no you didn't nobody did no you
you know who did Republicans did
conservatives did Libertarians did scary
people like Ron DeSantis did and uh and
a whole bunch of other Red State
Governors did but suddenly now that now
that people haven't been wearing masks
and places are thinking about bringing
bass Mac bringing masks back suddenly
they're like oh yeah yes we do believe
in that localism as long as it's going
to bring back back masks it's so
freaking crazy it's just so absolutely
insane but it is coming back and they
love Draconian policies they love
policies that will control you that have
nothing to do with science etc etc uh
here's what's going on in San Diego
right now we've got San Diego USD
President Sharon Whitehurst Payne uh
she's gonna mask up those kids because
apparently science parents who who don't
want to wear a mask indoors in school
are there any other options for them
for the fall there are some options they
can go to our school that's online
um they can opt not to return to the
regular school but to go to the school
where they don't have to go to school at
all other than via zoom and um that's
the easiest way for folks what about the
summer school what if they were already
enrolled in the summer school and now
they get this mask mandate and they're
not comfortable with wearing a mask
they really should wear the mask even if
they're not comfortable what should they
do they should just let make it known
that they don't feel comfortable and at
that point just not return
all right look if you live in San Diego
San Diego and you've got kids in that
school get your kids out you are a child
abuser if you're sending your kids to
school to have an unscientific piece of
cloth wrapped around their face that
does absolutely nothing we know that all
the masks except the n95s do nothing so
if you want to put your kid which and
kids have a 99.999999 survival rate on
cobit and we're two and a half years
past the beginning of this freaking
thing if you want to wrap your kid in
one of those you're also a psycho but if
you want to do it I guess go ahead and
then when your kid uh takes you out
early you know when you're like 85 and
they've got you on the machine and your
kid finally rips their mask off and then
they pull the the life support from you
you'll know why but okay if you want to
do that go to town have fun
um but crazy you're crazy people who
live in California your Psychopaths
you're abusing your children and that
woman she has no expertise in anything
she's not a scientist masks do not work
kids are not getting sick it's up to
choice and of course what her
alternatively oh we'll send you to zoom
school and we know that kids are getting
stupider they are literally getting
stupider kids are not speaking as early
as they should young toddlers we know
that the education level third graders
are now basically first graders fifth
graders or third graders like none of
this is working but if you people want
to be part of this go be part of it we
found an image of this woman Barbara
Barbara Federer she is the LA Department
she's the health lady in La I when I
lived in La I had a picture of this
woman in my bedroom and I would throw
darts at it at night just before I went
to bed she's the woman in charge of
locking down LA and putting the mask on
and everything else she's the one that
wants to bring the masks back can we get
her picture
so that's Barbara Ferrer is it fairer or
Federer or whatever her name is doesn't
matter doesn't matter what her name is
um and uh we found this other picture of
her because I knew I had seen her
sometime in the eight oh there she is
yes she actually also played the Evil
preacher in pollster in Poltergeist
remember that God is in his holy Temple
freaked me out as a kid freaked me out
but there she is again I'm not sure
which one's scarier to be quite there it
says we should have got Skeletor in the
mix too but if you want to take your
health advice from these people then
have at it if you want that woman on the
zoom call to lock your kids up in San
Diego have fun if you want Skeletor to
uh tell you to put a mask on in La have
at it there's nothing I can do for you
people at this point we tried uh but
what I've been hinting at for this whole
show is not just the insanity of the
left it's that actually people are
rejecting their ineptitude their
incompetence and their General
BS how about that uh and there is good
news because people are rejecting it
well now Anthony fauci the biggest con
artist possibly in American history a
man who was literally sending emails to
friends telling them to go on vacation
in Mexico and not wear masks because
they don't work while he was telling us
to double mask a man who pushed mandates
and vaccines on everyone who's now
admitting vaccines really don't do
anything uh he's actually going to
retire because he wants to do other [ __ ]
obviously you can't go on forever I do
want to do other things in my career
even though I'm at a rather Advanced age
I have the energy and the passion to
continue to want to pursue other aspects
of my professional career and I'm going
to do that sometime I'm not exactly sure
when but I don't see myself being in
this job to the point where I can't do
anything else after that so that's the
reason it has nothing to do with
pressures nothing to do with all the
other nonsense that you hear about all
the Bobs and the slings and the arrows
that has no influence on me yeah I mean
that's just a lie right it's like nobody
believes you anymore you're a fraud and
a con man and I know you are the highest
paid person in the federal government
and I have no doubt that you've made
Millions on however you figured out how
to monetize this stuff and it was your
NIH that funded some of the stuff at the
Wuhan lab and all of those things but
it's not you're not retiring because any
of that because people are sick of your
nonsense and everybody was happy
basically when you got coveted you're
not preparing because of any of that
you're sorry because you want to do
other things other science things you're
80 you're 80. you know you want to do
other science things yeah okay uh but
the Common Thread here is that people
aren't buying the nonsense no one said
that fauci is retiring there's a sense
of relief right you're watching this
right now I'm sure you were relieved oh
okay no more fouchy it's a relief from
the nonsense and the hypocrisy uh and
and that is good the more that that
feeling spreads like oh those people are
boy those people are that woman she
wants me to put my kid in a mess she's
nuts oh that guy wants me to get
injected with this weird thing he's
crazy oh you know that guy who lives is
on a cliff right on the water's edge
who's screaming about climate change
that's weird oh that multi-millionaire
socialist who has three houses wants me
to pay more in taxes I've had enough of
that people are starting to get it you
get it okay and we've got more evidence
of that uh here is Senator Kennedy and
man the guys got away with words and has
has really become a leading uh sort of
[ __ ] detector in the government uh
he is not into this Joe Biden fella he
way through his turn
and he's already a lame duck
the majority of Americans think he
shouldn't run for reelection the
majority of Democrats think he won't
shouldn't run for reelection
um a lot of his colleagues are already
talking about running against him and
the only way he's going to find his
footing and my judgment and the only way
that uh the American people are going to
to be better off is to reverse his woke
policies it's just that simple you reap
what you sow otherwise I mean the
American people are just going to
continue to uh tonight trusty meat with
a with a glow stick
yeah everyone gets it everyone gets it
and by the way when this thing about you
know these old people shouldn't be in
charge and I always say it's not about
it's not about age right you can be in
your late 70s early 80s you could
probably be I would say
like around 85 of your former self
probably it's your mid late 80s at this
point and plenty of people in their 90s
are living perfectly good lives should
they be the president of the United
States should they be on call 24 hours a
day should be they'd be flying all over
the world and time changes and all of
these other things probably not that but
the point is uh Kennedys up there
engineers and you can see he's just
significantly sharper than Joe Biden so
it's not about age it's about what's
happening to Joe Biden's brain which
they cannot hide much longer but also as
we've been showing you for a couple
weeks now there is something interesting
happening because the party is realizing
that they're done with him and he is
going to be the sacrificial lamb he
thought he was giving them everything
they wanted and perhaps he did but he
didn't realize that the last thing that
they wanted was him meaning oh we'd have
to take someone out to really accomplish
what we're doing and Usher in even more
insanity but the media is picking up on
it they realize Biden is Dead Man
Walking
how is Biden doing compared to his
predecessors
one way we look at that Jake we asked
folks do you believe Joe Biden has the
right priorities okay so right now only
31 say yes President Biden has the right
priority 68 say no that's his modern era
predecessors look at that not very well
31 for Biden is clearly the low water
mark of all Trump Obama Bush and Clinton
on this score Jake so what's really
incredible about that if you were
looking at those numbers so Trump's low
water mark was 44 now remember he was
the most polarizing president in history
that he was Hitler and he was mean and
he was grabbing people by this thing and
he was doing all this bad stuff and
everyone hated him and the entire
machine was against him and he only got
to 44 Biden's at 31 now maybe that has
something to do with the price of gas
and the crazy War and the supply chain
and just the General State of nonsense
in boys or girls and a whole bunch of
everything else
um but what why is the unpopularity
accelerating because I actually don't
think it's just policy it's not just
policy it's it's their complete
disregard for sanity it's like people
can put up with a lot of stuff they
really can people can put up with
ineptitude and high taxes and all this
stuff but it's the basic assault on
reality that people can't and what what
happens with the left always is the the
radicals always eat the same people so
speaking of radicals here is Vermont
Senator socialist with three houses and
millionaire Bernie Sanders and he's
freaking out because Joe manchin who is
a Democrat isn't given him everything
that he wants Senator Joe manchin of
course abruptly pulled the plug this
week on the democratulations
abruptly on Friday you didn't abruptly
do anything he was here
president's agenda
so what you have here is Joe manchin
making a decision for himself that's how
the Senate works now I understand they
don't like the Senate they don't like
every state having two Representatives
so that it can balance out state power
they don't want that they want mob rule
the left ones well they want their
people in charge and then to have the
mob rule right they would gladly take
minority rule if they could rule over
everybody else they just want Power
ultimately either way but it's
incredible uh I I honestly don't see how
Bernie can look himself in the mirror I
don't know how any socialist can look
themselves in the mirror but I guess a
millionaire socialist can look
themselves in a mirror in a very
expensive mirror but he lacks any
self-awareness just like all of the left
all of these woke series it's like
Mansion saying hey maybe we shouldn't
print all this money maybe we shouldn't
give the president unlimited capacity to
give other countries money maybe we
shouldn't give the president unlimited
capacity over all of our economy and to
manage climate as if these morons like
ao's AOC and any of these people they
couldn't manage their they couldn't
manage a McDonald's much less manage the
climate and I'm not even denigrating
someone who manages McDonald's I'm sure
it's a very complex thing to do right uh
but but Bernie just oh mansion's a bad
dude because he's not giving me enough
power to do all the stuff that I want
but getting to this idea of how they've
assaulted reality and how when they
assault reality and we all know it it
actually turns into things in real life
so do you remember this we've played
this a couple of times before the
election and not a lot of people played
this but I thought this was a seriously
important moment Joe Biden was at some
gender conference or lgbtq conference or
what are these rainbow conferences and
uh they asked and by the way in prison
in prison the determination should be
that your sexual identity is defined by
what you say it is not what in fact the
prison says it is and in that case you
should be entitled also to OGBYN anyway
you didn't ask that question all right
muddled pool doesn't even know what he's
saying you know he doesn't believe any
of it but but in essence they're okay so
that you should choose which prison you
want to go to so let's say you're a dude
I don't know you murder and rape 20
chicks murder rape the whole thing
pillage steal a lot of stuff do some bad
stuff
but then they get you on trial and they
find you guilty and then you go I'm a
chick I'm a chick I want to go to Chick
prison I like chick prison I saw Orange
is the New Black seems fun over there
let's go uh well Joe Biden is saying you
should be allowed to do that
do you think that has real world
consequences how about this headline
from uh this is two days ago 27 year old
transgender inmate who impregnated two
women moves to Men's prison so that dude
who you're seeing there in the corner
became that chick who you're seeing
there on the side raped two women in a
female prison and now is moving back to
Men's prison
you get it you get it so what do we have
to do what do we have to do well we have
to not only expose it okay we do that
all the time here and hopefully you guys
are doing it however you can in your own
life and hopefully you're getting on
school boards and hopefully you're
fighting to whatever ability you're able
to fight but we also have to elect
people who will cleanly and clearly tell
the truth and there are some of them
there are some of them there's obviously
Rod DeSantis here in Florida there's Kim
Reynolds in Iowa there are plenty of
people that are doing this to one extent
or another okay there's Carrie Lake
who's hopefully going to be governor in
Arizona there are plenty of people that
are doing this but now I want to show
you video I just thought this was so
perfect and it's such a perfect example
of how about a clean clear answer
without any of the nonsense uh this is
my friend and I believe the next senator
from the great state of Arizona Blake
Masters on Tucker talking about
immigration and what do we actually have
to do under Joe Biden's leadership uh
the southern borders become a welcome
map for the cartels you know the cartels
they're the only people who have gotten
richer under Joe Biden except of course
for Nancy Pelosi Tucker nobody has the
right to come to America that's a
privilege but every American citizen has
the right to public order and you know
the situation at the border it's a pilot
program for everything the Democrats
plan to do to the whole country right
completely abandon the rule of law and
call you crazy if you complain about it
but most people just want the law to be
enforced unfortunately the Democrats are
the party of lawlessness and
intimidation right they'll intimidate
anyone who dares to speak out well we
have to speak out we have to take back
power right now otherwise the Democrats
will put a gag on your mouth and call it
democracy
clean clear and honest you don't have a
right to be an American it's a privilege
to be an American and what do we want we
want people to live by the law live by
the law you want to come here it's still
the place that everyone wants to come to
despite you know the the patriarchy and
capitalism's evil and found it on
slavery and all that means stuff but AOC
never leaves
you still want to come people still
breaking in I mean it's the reverse of a
zombie movie that's what we're doing
here right I just started watching
Resident Evil and in zombie movies
you're always running away from the
zombies here the zombies are coming to
us and we're and the lefties are
welcoming them come oh zombies come over
and I'm not comparing immigrants to
zombies although in those videos it sort
of looks the same but you get the idea
you get the idea everyone still wants to
come here we don't have thousands of
people rushing our Southern border to
get to Mexico even though as Jill Biden
would say those Taco people down there
are wonderful people with their
margaritas and their chimichangas you
see okay so stick around for a cold
close people but we've got some comments
from the locals Community TK says I will
never understand why people who call
themselves feminists seem to have no
problem erasing females it is the it is
the end result of leftism which is not
connected to anything having to do with
reality but everything to do with power
when you when you got a quality when
women got equality when gays got
equality when black people got equality
you're supposed to
okay guys let's move on maybe the world
is not perfect but we got equality we
got a chance let's say see how we can
set off into the world and make the best
lives for ourselves but now it's on us
and sure maybe there were things before
us that weren't quite right maybe there
was some problems maybe somebody
discriminated against me in the past or
my father before that or whatever it
might be but now it's on you to fix
things they can't leave well enough
alone so the same I mean it's
extraordinary the same exact people
who were fighting the man and and
burning their bras at Berkeley in the
name of free speech are now shouting
down women like JK Rowling just because
she doesn't want a dude to win a women's
swimming event in high school it's
absolutely incredible but if you really
understand the ideology it actually
makes perfect sense tale Says Megan and
Harry remind me of the rich guy and wife
from Gilligan's Island just not as funny
that's good it was uh who the rich guy
was uh uh what was his name the rich guy
and you guys don't know you kids I got a
bunch of kids in here uh what was his
name uh the rich guy in Gilligan's
Island and his wife yeah Mr Powell
Powell Mr Howell and his wife the blonde
she didn't know what was going on and Mr
hone called like this you know he's very
rich and rich people used to talk like
this uh Amy Says Meghan Markle is as
black as Elizabeth Warren is Cherokee
ain't it the truth God these people
they're the they're all they're the
racists they're everything they say we
are guys if you want to play along
during the show if you want to get
videos early and add free and chat with
me and a whole bunch more uh you can
join us at
reubenreport.locals.com we are off to
shoot some guns they say you should get
hopped up on sugar and eat a lot of
donuts before you go shoot things right
that's the that's what you're supposed
to do so uh we got some more Donuts
downstairs we're gonna carb load get
some sugar in the system get out on a
Hot 100 degree day in the middle of
South Florida in a field and shoot some
iguanas I hope you do whatever makes you
happy for the rest of the day and we
will cold close you with the woman who's
going to be president once they get rid
of Joe come on Harris
you know I asked my team to to you know
I remember Venn diagrams those three
circles right and then let's just see
where they overlap
so I asked my team I said you know do a
Venn diagram on two circles for me
um and and in particular